bonjour alexis est ce que c'est une
grande est ce que c'est une vraie
réforme de la justice à quels
changements les français doivent-ils
s'attendre à non c'est une petite
réforme de la justice où on voit bien
derrière
l'avocat médiatique qui était eric
dupond-moretti donner toute l'importance
sensible aux justement au procès
médiatique avec cette idée de filmer les
pros c'est avec cette idée de recourir
aux eaux cour criminelle
eric dupond-moretti temps garde des
sceaux est très différente de eric
dupond moretti l'avocat
et il gère la pénurie de moyens tout
simplement ils essayent de faire avec ce
qu'il a c'est à dire une justice qui
manque de personnel une justice qui
manque de cours et une justice aussi qui
manque également de l'ale pénitentiaire
qui va avec
rappelez vous quand il était arrivé
qu'il avait pris ses fonctions sa
première visite était en prison et il
voulait désengorger les prisons
françaises depuis son arrivée il n'en
est rien on a plus de monde en
population carcérale que qu'avant et la
réforme qu'il fait bien il gère le fait
qu'il n'y ait pas assez de personnel
pour juger donc avec ces cour criminelle
avec l'idée aussi de réduire les jurys
populaires à certains près ce procès
médiatique tandis que le reste serait
jugée entre les pères ce qui va à
l'encontre de ce qui étaient ses
convictions lorsque lui même était
avocat et défendez tout à fait inverse
on est loin de la justice impopulaires
qu'il défende est dans la vie civile ce
que vous diriez qu eric dupond moretti
et finalement confronté à l'exercice du
pouvoir je crois qu'il est confronté à
l'exercice du pouvoir suffisamment
malléable aussi pour obéir puisque c'est
un gouvernement qui est entièrement
soumis aux volontés des modèles mâcon
qui souhaite réformer l'état en
profondeur on le voudrait que cette
réforme de l'ena avec cette guerre
permanente avec les différents corps et
les administrations donc il va dans ce
sens là puisque finalement on prend goût
sans doute au palais de la république
alors qu'il commençait une carrière à
toulouse sur les planches au théâtre et
ailleurs de nouveaux nouvelle vie
médiatique le voilà ministre peut-être
qu'il y prend goût effectivement ou bien
peut-être qu'il se dit que oui
maintenant qu'il a en main les
différentes fiches il n'est plus avocat
il a autre chose à défendre et qu'il va
faire comme le disait de manière assez
pragmatique mais aussi assez peu
ambitieuse une réforme a minima pour
gérer le manque de moyens de la
justice française alors vous en avez
évoqué quelques unes mais quelle mesure
en particulier suscite davantage votre
votre attention dans cette danse projet
de loi pour réformer la justice
évidemment cette mesure de filmer les
procès puisque en france alors qu'on
pouvait le photographier et filmer les
procès ça a été un peu dans les années
40 50 6 me semble pour ne pas gêner
justement le musée de la vie roulement
de du procès et l'idée c'est de revenir
à une version un peu plus américaine du
spectacle est là où il faudrait filmé et
c'est vrai que eric dupond-moretti n les
caméras lui qui a été ce soft avocat
nommé acquittator 1 qui a quitté plus
d'une centaine plusieurs centaines de
condamnés de justiciables et le voilà
donc qui voudrait que ce les procès
soient diffusés à la fois pendant après
à des fins de formation donc ça ça pose
question puisque ça changerait la façon
dont on fait la justice
le reniement de la justice populaire
avec les jurés qui serait utilisé a
minima même s'il se défend face à l' afp
on vous n'avez pas compris ma réforme
en fait je redonne toute son importance
ont juré puisqu'on on a revu la la la la
norme de de vote pour l'acquittement ou
non et puis il ya une petite ligne - qui
a retenu mon attention qui est fait je
pense pour les amis d'eric
dupond-moretti parce que c'est un petit
détail d'importance en lien avec les
affaires médiatiques
la personne qui a été publiquement
présenté dans les médias comme coupables
de faits faisant l'objet de l'enquète
aurez accès au dossier afin de pouvoir
se défend donc on voit bien que là c'est
l'avocat par contre de personnalités
médiatiques qui va faire un cadeau
peut-être à des amis en temps voilà
comme ça vous aurez de quoi préparer
bien mieux votre défense si vous êtes
vous même victime d'un procès médiatique
avant même qu'il soit filmé et donc on
voit bien que tout au tourne autour de
cette transparence de cette idée de
médias de cette idée de médiatisation et
très peu finalement
au niveau des moyens de la justice et je
crois que c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
la plupart des magistrats et des avocats
sont plutôt critique vis-à-vis de cette
réforme est puisque une réforme en
profondeur aurait sans doute revu ce
lien de vassalité entre les juges et le
pouvoir politique pour avoir une vraie
justice indépendante
avec aussi peut-être un organisme de
contrôle des juges
aujourd'hui c'est loin d'être le cas
et puis revoir les rôles bien sûr du
parc et des procureurs et la façon dont
toute cette justice aujourd'hui en
france est assez particulière compte
tenu du lien direct avec le politique à
l'objectif de ce projet de loi objectif
mise en avant
c'est de restaurer la confiance dans la
justice à vous entendre on n'y est pas
du tout avec ce texte
je crois que la confiance dans la
justice
elle dépendra de la façon dont elle est
rendue dans à la fois les affaires
médiatiques mais aussi au quotidien
on ne peut pas continuer d'avoir une
sorte de justice de classe de justice à
deux vitesses où des personnalités
influentes finalement échappent à la
justice systématiquement ou arriva à
louvoyer avec bien sûr des avocats comme
eric dupond moretti qui peuvent les
défendre et puis de l'autre côté des
pauvres bougres qui parce qu'ils ont
bravé le couvre-feu plusieurs fois se
retrouve directement en prison l'idée
bien sûr c'est d'aller plus loin peut
faire une justice où effectivement là le
mot justice aura son importance et que
on juge en fait à la fois dans la
formation des magistrats dans la façon
dont ils rendent le droit à la fois
l'humain mais aussi la façon dont la
société va faire cette justice qui donne
confiance parce qu'aujourd'hui les
procès qu'on voit ou bien les affaires
emblématiques ont plutôt tendance à
rendre les français nerveux quand on
parle de justice ou à des chiens plutôt
que confiant merci beaucoup pour votre
regard d'éditorialistes alexis pourra
bientôt